Neiman Peak disorder is a rare inherited
disorder where body's ability to
metabolize fat is abrogated this is a
lysosomal storage disorder and in this
disease phingomyeline and cholesterol
breakdown and transport is abrogated
in type A and type B's a pneumonic
disease sphingomyelin doesn't get broken
down in a normal way
because the sphingomyelinase enzyme
which is encoded by smpd1 Gene
is basically mutated that is why
sphinomyelinase activity is abrogated
and the breakdown doesn't happen in case
of pneumonic disease type c the npc1 and
NPC type 2 genes are mutated which
abrogates the cholesterol transport
hepatosplenomegaly disrupted bile flow
jaundice and bruising is common sin
symptom in case of type A and type B
type c is associated with several
neurological symptoms inheritance
pattern is autosomal recessive it can be
diagnosed using blood test and there is
no treatment